so for those of you that might not know
last year I decided to do something
called challenge charlie where I would
do 25 users submitted challenges the
last challenge that I did was about five
months ago and that was the third one so
a bit behind the third challenge that I
chose was to shave all of my hair off
for charity I didn't post a video of
that anywhere because I did it live on
the internet but here is a snippet over
here
Oh in case you missed it but today I
decided that I would finally return to
the world of challenge charlie so the
challenge I picked was to wear all of my
clothes at the same time
this is submitted by pointless Katie no
pointless Kate CY bunny so without
further ado or whatever here is me
putting on all of my clothes
do you like my tripod it's a stack of
books and boxes okay let's go already
this is quite uncomfortable which is a
good sign it's getting on here so put on
all of your clothes like an idiot
and understand why I need to own so many
t-shirts Oh
surely I just need like seven of them oh
this is crazy
I've got to medium size two t-shirts now
the workers all look fine put them well
[Music]
ah okay hello Zelda oh this should have
been in the small pile oh okay it's
going to go on wherever I need help
putting somebody help me please it's the
last medium-sized t-shirt laughter this
is all big ones and then I got to do the
jumpers oh my god oh this is my Julia
Nunes t-shirt I like Julia oh this one
isn't going on I'm so afraid of taking
one of these off I don't I don't I don't
want to think about the stage actually
last t-shirt my big orange ah success on
the t-shirt from oh look at all of these
jumpers I had to pop ah this just isn't
going to happen it's going to try and
pop a few I don't think I can get them
all on it's the biggest hoodie that I
own and then after all of these I only
have two pairs of trousers to put on
we'll bring you a bit closer for this
one I don't want you to miss out on any
of the trouser action
even though these ones are actually the
oldest pair of trousers that I own
they're actually the biggest ones I used
to really like wearing baggy jeans when
I was a kid I thought it was a cool
skater boy or whatever oh no that's not
going to happen cool oh it's it's hot
surprisingly socks yay tada
now for my gloves some fingerless gloves
well my dad found out about my
fingerless gloves he went out and he
bought me um these leather gloves which
was nice of it and then one of my
friends told me that were actually
gloves for ladies not actually men's
gloves gloves for the females so um now
I don't wear them out a car get the last
pair on mm oh that's just a challenge to
throw the hats on because I got these
gloves on
[Music]
oh there we go
I am now officially wearing all of my
clothes right o-tar challenge completed
Oh God and now I had to take it all off
brilliant oh and that right there is all
of the clothes that I was just wearing
right I hope that was more fun for you
to watch and it was for me to do I'm
gonna go and do one of two things either
have a nap little siesta or I'm going to
have a nice cold bath no I actually
didn't have a bath or a nap I decided
just to go straight to editing the video
because I'm dedicated like that but yeah
thanks for watching bye are